[Música]
[Aplausos]
o brasil é o maior país do mundo em
número de processos na justiça
temos sempre 15 milhões de processos e
somos 210 milhões de habitantes
aqui em a cada cinco segundos uma nova
sanção ingressa no judiciário para
resolver esses conflitos
a gente precisa estudar direito cível
privado trabalhista consultar códigos
leis regulamentos redigir minutas
protocolar pagar taxas esperar prazos
das varas dos fóruns dos tribunais que
são divididos por regiões graus
instâncias cansativa e por mais que os
nossos juízes sejam muito eficientes e
eles são um dos juízes mais eficientes
do mundo é muito difícil dar conta desse
volume de processos num país onde a
primeira opção para as pessoas
resolverem seus conflitos é ajuizar uma
ação quando era estudante de direito na
universidade de roma eu me inscrevi uma
disciplina que se chamava métodos
alternativos de solução de conflito era
uma disciplina muito diferente de tudo
que eu já o dia que eu já tinha visto um
direito a gente não estudava o processo
mas sim o comportamento dos indivíduos
estudávamos técnicas para a resolução e
gestão de conflitos
achava aquilo muito prático porque a
gente consegue usar no dia a dia
afinal de contas a gente passa o dia
todo resolvendo evitando o rei mediando
conflitos no trabalho na família na
vizinhança
e por que não nos ensinam essas técnicas
nas escolas e universidades porque somos
tão programados há sempre delegar a
solução de um conflito por um terceiro
no primeiro dia de aula o professor
abriu um livro muito antigo mas não era
nenhum livro de direito romano era
bíblia e leu a passagem de quando jetro
visitou moisés aos pés do monte sião
onde moisés se sentar
para fazer as vezes de juiz possa
observar aquelas cenas jetro disse
moisés que por mais sábio que ele fosse
ele não deveria tirar o poder das
pessoas de se entenderem que elas mais
do que ninguém conhece o que é melhor
para elas
depois dessa eu nunca mais parei de me
interessar por esses métodos e seguir
trabalhando estudando em alguns outros
países
quando eu voltei para o brasil o que
mais me incomodava era saber que somos o
país mais litigante do mundo e sempre me
perguntei mas o brasileiro gosta mesmo
de processar gastar dinheiro esperar
muito tempo por uma solução
o brasileiro esse povo que tem uma
vocação nata para a comunicação e um
talento incrível para encontrar soluções
criativas
será mesmo que ele gosta de resolver
seus conflitos assim o brasil pode ser o
maior litigante
mas o brasileiro não é ele só não
conhece ainda uma nova forma de resolver
seus conflitos
essa nova forma essa nova opção para
resolver conflitos é a mediação
a mediação é uma dança um dos métodos
alternativos de solução de conflito onde
um terceiro imparcial e sem poder
decisório chamado mediador atua como
facilitador do diálogo entre as partes e
as auxilia na elaboração de um acordo
a mediação em poder das partes para que
elas mesmas resolvam seus conflitos e
não é algo novo a mediação uma das
técnicas mais antigas do mundo existe
desde os primórdios da civilização
humana em todas as culturas têm seu
próprio mecanismo de mediação só vamos
pensar na cultura judaica o rabino
mediador por excelência na cultura
islâmica no budismo nas tribos indígenas
africanas no mundo cristão hoje o papa é
um grande mediador num mundo ocidental a
prática da mediação ela foi abandonada
medida em que a sociedade foi evoluindo
e foi criando estruturas mais
sofisticadas como estado a divisão dos
poderes
e essa máquina de produzir burocracia
que conhecemos hoje
hoje a gente chegou ao excesso de
quantificação e nenhum estímulo
incentivo para o entendimento humano
mas será que não chegou a hora da gente
mudar essa estrutura de buscar uma
configuração que atenda às nossas
necessidades de hoje será que a gente
consegue será que é possível trazer para
a resolução de conflitos o que o bê fez
com o transporte cerb com a skol
hospedagem netflix com a produção de
conteúdo audiovisual como a gente pode
mudar a resolução de conflitos no brasil
bom primeiro de tudo a gente vai
precisar de leis e tenho boas notícias
já temos legislação para isso dos 115
milhões de processos ajuizados 40% deles
podem ser resolvidos através de mediação
esses são os direitos em que depende da
vontade e autonomia das partes para
serem exercidos
o estado já tutela regulamento controla
e já ditou esses direitos vocês podem
resolver entre vocês mediação já está
prevista na constituição tem uma lei
própria está também no novo código de
processo civil
se a gente conseguisse utilizado a
mediação nessa proporção de geraria uma
economia de 63 bilhões por ano aos
cofres públicos
a gente precisa utilizar a máquina
pública e os juízes para casos mais
complexos casos onde as partes não
conseguiram se entender nos estados
unidos começou a mediação que a gente
conhece hoje e 95 por cento da demanda é
resolvida extrajudicialmente ou seja
fora da justiça e por quê porque é muito
simples resolver
o procedimento leva de um dia há três
meses e termina sempre com um acordo
construído pelas próprias partes um
acordo ganha ganha
e não mais uma sentença dada por um
terceiro onde uma parte perde ea outra
ganha a mediação pode ser aplicada
quando já existe um processo as partes
fazem o acordo encerram o caso na
justiça pode ser pode ser utilizada
quando ainda não existe um processo
ela pode ser prejudicial que a mediação
realizada dentro dos tribunais de
justiça pública dentro da administração
pública e extrajudicial que a mediação
privada realizada por câmeras empresas
mediadores privados e pode ser utilizado
em diversas áreas do direito
a mediação a diferença do processo
ela não trabalha posição direito e
provas
ela trabalha as relações e os interesses
dos indivíduos naquele conflito resolver
um problema ganha no processo não quer
dizer resolver um problema há pouco
tempo atrás eu escutei de um promotor de
justiça do ceará uma briga que durou
décadas é suco entre um grupo
empreiteiro e um grupo de ambientalistas
em torno de um empreendimento em
fortaleza
depois quando ao sentença do último
recurso veio e foi favorável para a
empreiteira
a sentença já não atendia mais eo dano
que geraria para o contexto geral era
tão grande que o empreiteiro rasgou
sentença e foi buscar um acordo com um
grupo de ambientalistas a mediação já é
uma realidade no brasil hoje tem
estatísticas excelentes de ouro de 84
por cento das pessoas que são convidadas
para fazer uma mediação 84 por cento
aceitam 72% realizam os acordos e melhor
ainda
95% cumprem os acordos porque essa taxa
tão alta
simples porque um acordo voluntário
feito pelas próprias partes levando em
consideração as reais possibilidades e
necessidades de cada um
imagina se a gente conseguir resolver
esses casos de mediação sem sair de casa
ou do escritório que as pessoas pudessem
escolher como quando e onde resolver
esses tribunais de justiça que tem que
dar conta de um estoque de 115 milhões
de processos ea cada cinco segundos uma
nova ação pudesse realizar mediações sem
limitação de tempo espaço
vamos precisar de tecnologia em 2015 foi
fundada a mall mediação online uma
plataforma onde desde o envio do caso
passando pelo agendamento da sessão a
realização assinatura do acordo com
validade jurídica o pagamento
o armazenamento dos dados da
inteligência dos dados tudo online
acessível de um telefone ou um
computador
hoje é possível realizar mediações entre
casais que não podia ou não queria estar
presentes fisicamente casos ele
herdeiros espalhados pelo mundo todo ou
mesmo casos conflitos de condomínio com
vizinhos que não conseguem estar
presentes no mesmo edifício mediação
resolve também muitos conflitos entre
empresas e seus consumidores em uma
empresa no interior paulista e que
concede consórcio para caminhoneiros e
hoje ela fala e resolve conflitos
companheiros no brasil todo
antes eles não conseguiram resolver os
conflitos porque os caminhoneiros nunca
podiam estar presentes no local com dia
e hora marcada claro estavam sempre em
viagens a trabalho
hoje eles precisam somente parar o
caminhão encontrar wifi se conectar na
internet e fazer a mediação com o
advogado da empresa
as empresas precisam de canais saudáveis
e flexíveis adequados à nossa realidade
as empresas brasileiras estão presentes
em 83% dos casos e todo ano elas gastam
2 por cento da receita total com
demandas judiciais
ano passado esse valor foi de 125
bilhões de reais
imagine esse dinheiro aplicado em
melhorias de produtos e serviços que a
mediação online se propõe a fazer é isso
oferecer um novo canal para pessoas
empresas instituições
nossa missão é tornar os métodos
alternativos de solução de conflitos
civis a todos
a gente já trabalhou muitos casos e
agora que a gente vai precisar fazer
difundir a cultura da mediação e os
brasileiros já têm dado sinal de que
estão mudando a cultura do litígio pela
cultura da colaboração
a mesma pesquisa do conselho nacional de
justiça e bg é revelou que nos últimos
cinco anos das 11,7 milhões de pessoas
que buscaram uma solução para os
conflitos 30% delas ou seja quase quatro
milhões de pessoas já optaram pelos
métodos alternativos de solução de
conflito como a mediação
a gente precisa de uma nova experiência
na resolução de conflitos uma
experiência com economia de custos e
tempo e mais do que isso satisfação dos
resultados
hoje qual é a grande característica do
nosso tempo é a primeira vez na história
da humanidade que as 15 mil tribos do
planeta terra estão conectadas na mesma
rede
todas interligadas e falando ao mesmo
tempo vamos usar esse poder para
promover o entendimento humano
vamos resgatar o poder que temos de
resolver nossos próprios conflitos
o caminho para resolver a transformação
da resolução de conflitos no brasil já
está dado
já temos legislação tecnologia e mudança
cultural a nosso favor
estamos mais preparados do que
pensávamos
agora vamos utilizar e resolver
conflitos dessa nova forma
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]